avec le vingtième siècle sport afin en
france allons entrer dans la vie sociale
au cours des premières années peu
d'adeptes de disputer les compétitions
une organisation sportive était
pratiquement inexistant aujourd'hui le
ministère de la jeunesse et des sports a
décidé de spécialiser chaque région dans
une discipline particulière ainsi niort
et les deux sel devront désormais
persévérer dans le développement de la
natation
nous sommes allés rendre visite aux
responsables régionaux des sports à
niort
afin d'avoir quelques précisions sur les
possibilités d'adaptation de cette
nouvelle formule les installations
nautiques dans lequel vous évoluez en ce
moment consiste essentiellement en aba
110 olympique de 50 mètres sur ben
profonde à mettre 30 à 3 mètres 50 avec
plongeoir de trois mètres et gradins
pour environ 800 mille personnes d'un
autre côté il existe le bassin couvert
actuel de valse à mettre sur 15 profond
de 1 m 40 à 2 mètres 40 et qui permet
aussi bien l'apprentissage systématique
à la natation que le déroulement des
séances d'entraînement voir de
compétitions sportives nautiques dans le
cadre de la région et peut-être dans le
cadre national monsieur le directeur
départemental de la jeunesse et des
sports ou fait une expérience de
natation pourquoi et qui se trouvent
concernés par cette expérience
eh bien nous faisons une expérience de
natation d'abord pour utiliser cet
ensemble nautique et aussi pour répondre
aux désirs de notre ministère va
jeunesse eurosport qui nous a demandés
partout les installations correct le
permettait de faire des expériences
d'initiation sportive et à new york on
pouvait le constater est évident que
nous avons tenté la natation qui seront
concernés par cette expérience
et bien tout le monde mais tout
particulièrement les jeunes je dirais
aussi peut-être tout particulièrement
les scolaires que nous avons par un
système
ramassage amené ici par classe entière
aussi bien des élèves du premier degré
que des élèves du secondaire
il est bien évident que en dehors des
heures scolaires
ce bassin chauffé ouvert reçoit
également des apprentis des ouvriers des
étudiants et le soir plus
particulièrement tous les sportifs qui
désirent venir s'y entraîner
le virage
grosse difficulté évidemment c'est de ne
faire qu'une seule bras sous l'eau d'une
part et deuxièmement de rabattre ses
bras vers l'intérieur de la poitrine en
deux temps pour que la poussée puisse
étendre jusqu à la cuisse actuellement
nous sommes à une minute 12 secondes une
minute 19 da locales tant partie avoir
fait in 19
elle est un record 18 9 qui fit amené à
la natation
nous sommes en route doucement
c'est le sport
je choisis pour de sport auparavant je
fais du suicide
quel sens penses tu sers un jour sur 100
m
difficile à dire enfin
le relief le running 1017 est en train
de souvent jouer régulièrement
catastrophe par semaine qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces temps une 19 sur 100
m bien évidemment sur le plan régional
cela représente ce qui se fait de mieux
actuellement
n'est ce pas le meilleur temps actuels
réalisés dans le sang tout et c'est
celui de dany dalo en une minute 18 9
10e temps qu'il a réussi également n'est
ce pas à réaliser cette année mais sur
le plan national
évidemment
ce n'est pas encore ce qu'il faudrait
pour avoir une excellente performance en
brasse maintenant il faut réaliser une
minute 15 ces trois secondes nous le
gagnerons mais après l'entraînement
fractionné qui va commencer incessamment
et qui se terminera vers le début
juillet quels sont vos projets bien aimé
projet c'est d'abord de faire un
recrutement assez large
je voudrais bien pouvoir prospecter dans
le milieu scolaire chez les enfants très
jeunes
et lorsque j'aurai effectué cette
prospection je distinguerai ce qui
effectivement sont doués pour la
natation parce que pour la natation il
faut avoir un minimum de dons
flottabilité une certaine cohésion dans
la propulsion des jambes qu'elle soit
symétrique dans la brasse ou
alternatives dans le crawl et faut tout
de même avoir des dons essais dont nous
les exploiterons en fonction les vite
évidemment des nageurs que nous
trouverons nous pouvons d'ores et déjà
constater que ces nouveaux procédés sont
bénéfiques et que les rays récents
résultats obtenus sont plus que
convaincants
la piscine olympique de niort récemment
inauguré sera peut être appelée à vivre
des journées brillant espérons que nos
jeunes nageurs de tous les milieux des
agriculteurs aux scolaires des ruraux et
citadins pourront ainsi se perfectionner
et dans l'avenir emporté avec succès les
épreuves qui leur seront proposés